president biden's first weekend at the
white house and one of the most pressing
issues facing the nation
after repeatedly calling the coronavirus
pandemic a national emergency requiring
a wartime
effort response mr biden signed nearly
30
executive orders in his first three days
in office most of them addressed the
coronavirus and the economic fallout
from the pandemic
now he's arranging to meet with a
bipartisan group of lawmakers
in hopes of reaching a larger relief
plan
skyler henry is at the white house with
more this morning skyler good morning
hey dana good morning to you where
republican lawmakers have already balked
at president biden's massive coronavirus
relief plan especially given that
congress passed
a near trillion dollar plan at the end
of last year but the white house says
if measures aren't passed soon officials
fear the country will have to dig itself
out of a bigger economic hole
later president biden made it clear on
friday
his team is taking the pandemic head-on
adamant about delivering on a promise to
distribute more coronavirus vaccines
week before they're sin biden you crazy
you can't do 100 million in a hundred
days
well we're going to god will he not only
do 100 million we're going to do more
than that
the president signed two more executive
actions a day after unveiling his
economic recovery plan
addressing the ripple effects of the
pandemic one directs government agencies
to find ways to pay
all federal workers and contractors a
minimum wage of fifteen dollars an hour
the other urging the agriculture
department to boost pandemic food
benefits for low income families by 15
percent
all told the american rescue plan would
lift 12 million americans out of poverty
and cut child poverty in half
the white house admits it will take
bipartisan support to get the massive
near 2 trillion
relief plan passed but the price tag
isn't appealing to some republicans
there are some added items in there that
he's going to have a real tough time
getting through that really aren't part
of covet relief
he'll have to separate those out also
impacting the a deal
the senate's packed schedule so far only
having confirmed two of president
biden's cabinet picks
see you around campus the senate made
history
voting to confirm retired general lloyd
austin the country's first black defense
secretary
and on deck the nomination will be
reported
unanimously treasury secretary nominee
janet yellen
getting a vote of confidence out of
committee she'd be the first woman to
lead the department i think that
you're going to find quick approval but
don't forget
the ones that we've approved are
mostly connected with national security
and intelligence and defense
and they've always had a priority
whether you have a republican or
democrat president
white house press secretary jensachi
says president biden plans on rolling up
his sleeves and working with lawmakers
to negotiate a bipartisan
coveted relief plan jeff all right
skyler thanks very much